les secrétaires départementaux dans le
mouvement sont ceux qui ont la
responsabilité d'appliquer la ligne du
mouvement c'est un honneur de vous
accueillir dans cette maison qui est la
vôtre c'est vous le coeur de la
structure les secrétaires départementaux
c'est quand même la pierre angulaire
dans la construction de notre parti
s'est profondément notre originalité
c'est ce qui fait la marque de la
tradition notre famille politique et
c'est vous qui donnez le point de
stabilité
je voudrais aujourd'hui d'abord me
réjouir que nicolas sarkozy ait souhaité
ce moment de débat notre objectif notre
volonté c'est de resserrer ce lien très
fort entre le siège ici des républicains
et entre chacune des filles
nous n'aurons plus ce matin échanger de
manière tout à fait libres et ouvertes
et intéressante avec le président
nicolas sarkozy et avec les cadres
dirigeants du mouvement sur les grands
sujets qui animent notre parti c'est à
dire la vie des fédérations leur
animation leur financement tous les
sujets pas de sujet tabou
c est l occasion pour l'ensemble de ce
prêt d'un département d'autres se
retrouver au siège autour de l'équipe
dirigeante
on a pu poser toutes les questions et
partager toutes les difficultés que nous
pouvons rencontrer au quotidien un
échange très direct avec le président
nicolas sarkozy c'est compliqué quand on
est secrétaire départemental de
connaître tous les autres mais en fait
on s'aperçoit au cours de cette journée
on s'est aperçu qu'on avait tous les
mêmes problématiques
les mêmes attentes et les mêmes
aspirations face à tout ce qui se passe
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui en
particulier en france c'était
extrêmement constructif puisqu'en fait
ça permet à la fois d'avoir les
remontées d'informations du terrain et
puis aussi d'avoir le message donné par
le président du mouvement qui vient ré
expliquer aux secrétaires départementaux
quelle est la ligne de notre parti
pourquoi nous prenons des décisions pour
ensuite mieux en faire la pédagogie sur
le terrain cette journée est assez
exceptionnel sur le fond et sur la forme
j'ai été ravi que tout le monde parle un
vrai langage et on a senti vraiment une
grande famille politique on est tous se
souder et on est parti donc pour les
régionales
cet après midi nous avons réuni les
secrétaires départementaux et avec eric
woerth
nous leur avons présenté la nouvelle
plate forme de contributions sur
laquelle les français doivent venir
s'exprimer et faire des propositions
pour un projet alternatif pour notre
pays tout ne doit pas se passer à paris
on a besoin aussi de débattre partout en
france et donc là on a tous les outils
c'est ce qu'on voulait dire aux
secrétaires départementaux ils ont tous
les outils ils peuvent maintenant
travailler concrètement sur le terrain
et animer des débats
je dois dire que je n'ai pas été déçu ça
remonte le moral
et puis en même temps prend les
instructions parce que moi je me suis
toujours considéré comme étant le préfet
des républicains en moselle réfère
représentant nicolas sarkozy notre
président du préfet efficace d'un
mouvement efficace et qui a une vocation
c'est notamment permettent la reconquête
bien sûr au niveau national je suis venu
avec beaucoup de plaisir aujourd'hui
parce que il est important pour nous
responsables départementaux du plus
grand parti politique de france 2 se
retrouver avec aussi le privilège de le
côtoyer
nos responsables fils président qui nous
a fait l'honneur de passer une très
grande partie de la journée avec nous et
ça pour nous qui sommes sur le terrain
c'est un plus énorme